again I'm a biased commentator because
she made a huge difference for an author
I really love Andre to be as the third
when she selected house of sand and fog
and that was a book that I really
believed had a mass audience it went
through a real roller coaster on
publication it had been turned down by
22 publishers before I signed it up
which I didn't know at the time but I
had a real struggle in house to get it
signed up then everything started to go
right booksellers loved it the first
reviews were spectacular and three days
after publication the office father died
under to be a senior also wonderful
right are very highly regarded and all
of the publicity tour he's publicity
towards which I that at that time the
kind of physical publicity tour was the
most important thing in getting a book
to potentially get on the best our list
and Andre had to cancel his and so the
the book kind of stopped in terms of its
momentum then some months later it was
nominated for the National Book Award
and then there was a spike again a lot
of excitement and the there were 80
thousand copies provisionally ordered
waiting for the announcement at the
National Book Award winner if he won the
printing was all set to go and of course
he didn't win and he and he was very
happy to be at the National Book Award
winner dinner I don't think he really
cared whether he won or not he felt was
a privilege to be there but his agents
and I were devastated totally doesn't
say that he didn't win because we knew
that there were 80 thousand copies not
being printed so the book came out in
paperback it started to do well started
to get some reading group attention but
still it I think it had sold maybe a
thousand copies or something in
paperback excellent but nothing like the
two and a half million copies that sold
after Oprah shown her very strong
spotlight on it and it is a case with
many books where you you know that there
is actually a huge audience for that
book but there has to be a very bright
spotlight shone on it and and often that
doesn't happen so I'm very glad that she
had that great big star making spot
light to shine and it meant that a lot
of readers who were not necessarily
Oprah Watchers ended up finding out
about the book and reading it because it
became number one on the paperback
bestseller list because other people
were reading